il ya une personne qui souhaitait vous
faire faire un petit bisou pour
l'anniversaire c'est agathe on la voit
dans btp voilà tous les jolis dans
balances ton post agathe nous a fait un
petit bisou puisqu'elle est à miami
actuellement à regarder tibi ya un peu
de vent mais je ne pense qu à vous
aujourd'hui avec leur salut à toi sinon
je pense très fort à vous tous et agathe
agathe en fait elle n'est pas bien lille
et chérie elle a voulu nous faire un
petit coucou ce soit puisque agathe est
là
[Musique]
il arrive
bien sûr nadja c'est le sosie d'agathe
est franchement c'est incroyable quand
vous avez dit saint félicien est aussi
allé dit bonjour bonjour encore j'aime
bien merci merci d'être là merci félicia
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu peux me faire un grand
plaisir ce soir
est ce que tu peux aller faire un gros
bisou à kelly ça va mieux agathe et elie
ça y est c'est reparti l'arrière ça va
être les deux meilleurs amis du monde
les scieries on embrasse agathe qui est
vraiment agréable
ils pensent à nous et les chéris jsms
également de big flo et oli mecheri qui
dit qui dirait qu'ils disent et ban au
venturer galles tout le monde respect à
toi mon frérot en tant que fan d'abord
et en tant que frérot après je les
embrasse très fort mais un petit coucou
et un gros bisou un certain olivier
girault le frère olivier giroud
je suis content ça lui cyril voilà je
fais une petite vidéo en direct d'un
club
dounia je te souhaite tout le bonheur du
monde pour les années futures dans tpm
peut bien sûr se félicite pour les
les neuf ans déjà bon anniversaire à
avant ces super donc
voilà j'espère qu'on
salut mon tous les bals n'embrasse
olivier mon frère olivier gêne
énormément
voilà qui est un super mec et j'ai fait
un gros bisou et je vais venir le voir
dès le week-end prochain à londres voilà
comme ça oui oui magicien si on n'a plus
le droit d'avoir des amis on a des
ennemis merci est d'ailleurs membre
associé antoine griezmann que je vais
aller voir madrid dans deux semaines la
première chambre a également karim
benzema qui gérait non mais non non vous
offre un tour du monde et je vous
emmènerai valérie bénard alors ça serait
si je dois en choisir une ce sera vous
c'est amiens avec moi oui mais où
où vous voulez complètement confiance ah
oui c'est bien moi je suis un homme de
confiance professionnels et jamais joué
et même dans le milieu du sexe on
m'appelle darty